KOH KIM: Hi.
My name is Koh Kim.
I'm on the Google Play Business
Development team
covering games for
global and Korea.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA:
My name is Yoshi.
I'm also working for the
Google Play BD teams--
I'm on their Japan.
KOH KIM: We wanted to take some
time to share some pro
tips on how you as a game
developer or an app developer
can take your app or game to
Korea, Japan, or really any
other country.
So let's start about how big
this opportunity is in Asia,
specifically in Korea
and Japan.
So in the subways, you can see
that everyone is glued to
their smartphones.
And what are they doing
on those phones?
They're playing games.
And it's not just the subway,
it's while they're walking
down the street, heading
to school, heading to
restaurants, meeting
up with friends.
I mean, they are gaming
everywhere.
And what kind of phones do you
think that all these people
are playing their games on?
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Android.
KOH KIM: Android.
Especially true in Korea, where
everywhere is an Android
phone, and then even in
Japan and a lot of
parts of Asia as well.
And so how do you take advantage
of the opportunity
is that you really got to pick
the right game to export.
So what game in your portfolio
is really going to engage the
players that are in
these communities?
Well, let's take a look at some
of the most popular games
that are in Korea and
Japan right now.
So in Korea, we have games
such as "Dragon Flight,"
"Anipang." "Fish Island,"
"Isamaru," defense games such
as "Cat War." In a lot of
these things, you can
definitely tell that there's
a different art style and a
different way that players
actually would want to look at
these games and actually
feel like games.
And what is it like in Japan?
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: And in
Japan also, they are the
[INAUDIBLE]
games plus something like
puzzle functions
or like quiz effect.
KOH KIM: So what's an example
of a good localized game?
So let's take a look at Glu's
"Eternity Warriors 2." This is
a very good example of what you
can do to fully localize
your game for that market.
And so this is a screen shot of
the banner graphic that you
can see for both "Eternity
Warriors 2" in
Korea and in Japan.
And notice that they've
definitely taken and been
very, very detailed on the font
that they use, also the
way that they localize
to that audience.
So we think this is a very good
example of what a good
localized game can be
in Korea and Japan.
Which also means that
localization does not equal
translation.
Actually, can we repeat
this again?
Localization does not equal
to translation.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Yes.
KOH KIM: So this will carry
out throughout all our
presentation.
If there's one thing you should
remember, it's this.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: This
is a big point.
KOH KIM: So first impressions
do count.
Let's take a look at this game,
"Anomaly Korea," by 11
bit studios.
Actually, this game "Anomaly
Korea" is localized in Korean.
There is actually Korean
translations within the game.
What's actually very unfortunate
is within the
Google Play listing in Korea,
there's actually no Korean
screenshots, or banner graphics,
or anything that's
translating.
Which is actually very
unfortunate for the Korean
player who actually looked at
this game, was like oh, look.
And it's like this game
looks really cool,
really awesome graphics.
But they have no idea that
it's in Korean, because
everything in the description
is an English.
And this same could probably be
true for you guys in Japan,
too, right?
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA:
Yes, we do.
Everyone's hard to
read in English.
Once they are translated into
Japanese, they can't
understand what the game's on.
KOH KIM: Right.
So that's why you should
localize your listings to your
fans in Korean and Japanese,
especially if the game is
available in those languages.
If you look at "Gun Bros 2,"
what's great is that they
actually created specific
graphics, not only, obviously,
for the English game, but
for Korean and Japanese.
And I actually think the Korean
version of this graphic
is pretty cool looking.
I think the Japanese one looks
pretty cool as well.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
And so it's pretty different,
the Korean versions and
Japanese versions.
And then feature graphic as a
Korean version using entirely
the Koreans, and also the
Japanese version using the
original titles plus Japanese.
KOH KIM: And it's not just about
what's in the Google
Play store listing, it's all
about what you do within your
game as well.
So you really got to think like
your local gamer in the
sense of that you have to figure
out how your gamer
within Korea and Japan
is actually going
to play your game.
So we have two examples that
are actually very good
examples again.
We have "Beeline Smurf Village"
in Japanese actually.
And then we also have "Madfinger
Shadowgun DeadZone"
that's actually in Korean, but
also localized in many other
different languages.
And what's really great is that
they actually thought
about how the text is going to
fit within the context of
their game.
So in the case of "Smurf
Village," it's
actually pretty simple.
It's a social network game, so
they really did focus on
allowing the user to be able
to manipulate their village
and make the game changes
as necessary.
Whereas in "Shadowngun," it's
all about upgrading your
equipment, upgrading your
weaponry and choosing weapons.
So they actually made really
sure that all that text was
spot on and exactly what
a gamer in that
region would feel like.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: That
technically is not like a
machine language, right?
Like machine translation
language.
KOH KIM: Yeah, as far as some of
my Korean friends say, they
said it was like they didn't
even know it was developed by
a European developer, so
that's a good sign.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Let's talk
about a final layer in
the Asian language.
You can see the Asian language
is pretty different from the
English within the game.
So you can see that layout is
using the pretty weird font,
and also the layer is pretty
blocky in the Asian language.
KOH KIM: So the one thing you
do have to keep in mind is
that Asian languages do
present a little bit
differently from what English
or some of the European
languages can put into a game.
So sometimes you really got to
watch whether your menu button
is actually big enough to
fit that Asian language.
So this is definitely you should
take into mind, and
definitely something you tell
your QA teams to check on.
Now let's talk about speaking
the language.
And so what we mean by speak the
lingo is that there's some
things that a Korean and
Japanese game player is used
to when they encounter things,
such as price for example.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA:
This is pretty
important for the users.
KOH KIM: Yeah.
So you really got to make sure
whatever you set for your
in-app purchases or your prices
are actually the right
price for that region.
So what do I mean by this?
So typically in the US you see
a lot of things that are
$0.99, or in euros,
79 euro cents.
But in Korea and Japan, there's
no such thing as
prices that end in nines--
they actually end in zeros.
And so in the Korean, which
is in red, that's 1,001.
In Japanese, it's 100 yen.
So what we see most often
that's actually a pretty
common mistake is that we see
really weird currency
converted numbers.
So if you put in $0.99 into US,
you're actually going to
see 1,050A1, which is actually
a very weird number.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Yes,
KOH KIM: And the next important
thing is to provide
customer support in that
local language.
So what's often very frustrating
for any user is
that the customer service
representative can't
understand the language that
the user is complaining in.
So this is an example from
Japan, where actually the
replied review is in Japanese.
And so don't reply to
review in English.
You don't want to make your
users pissed off.
And finally, what we want to
end on is to know your
players' gameplay behavior.
What do I mean by this is that
oftentimes I like to say that
an Asia female casual game
player is a lot more hardcore
than an 18-year-old American
boy that's playing
first-person shooters.
And what do we mean by this?
It actually just means that
Asian players really go
through content like no other.
You've really got to think about
updates, you've got to
think about new content,
you've got
to think about events.
Yoshi, what do "Puzzle and
Dragon" do in terms of their
content updates?
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: They
do in every day is
their updated event.
KOH KIM: We're in the land
of super competitive, and
everyone wants to really
eat your content.
But that's a good sign, it just
means you're just going
to have to keep up.
So thanks for listening to
our presentation today.
If you have any other questions,
just let us know.
Thanks.
YOSHITSUGU HIROTAKA: Arigato.